Black people would be
perfectly justified
in only tending to issues
affecting the Black community.
Why you think Black superheroes
only save Black people?
They're busy.
They ain't got the time
to save the rest of the world.
That's a luxury that only
White superheroes have.
My neighborhood's great.
What else is going on
out here in the world?
At which point we detonate
the explosives,
and once again save the world.
Let's man up. Any questions?
Yeah, I got a question.
Why y'all always
got to say the world?
Why y'all never help me
with the problems
I'm dealing with up
in the hood?
Well, it's difficult
coordinating
all of our schedules.
Schedules.
I mean the avenging ones focus
on protecting all lives,
so we should start
with saving the world.
I get what you're saying,
but alien invasion
that don't happen
but once every couple of years.
Y'all ain't be doing shit
in between time.
I ain't seen you in the hood.
I ain't seen
Dracula cape in the hood.
I ain't seen none of y'all
come through.
Why you won't come
to the Black folks?
Well, if we help the world
at large
that trickles down
to those smaller communities.
Don't answer him.
He's not even an avenging one.
Because I ain't got the time
to be an avenging one.
Black superheroes
got to worry about
Black issues
in the Black community.
Well that's just shortsighted.
I mean take Black Cougar
for instance,
he understands that
being an avenging one
means saving the world first
before he works on his own-
Oh, oh. Got to stop you there.
I am only here
to protect my part of Africa.
But you said teamwork was the-
That was a lie.
White, I do not care about
White people's problems
unless those problems
affect my people of
Lawanda
See what I'm saying?
Stop getting Black superheroes
to solve your global issues.
Now your ass
ought to be ashamed.
Rounding up all these magical
White folks,
and then you won't bring
none of them to the hood,
fam. I oughta pluck
that other eyeball out.
And where was you at
when Dr. King got shot?
You got the technology.
You could have saved Dr. King.
No, no. (arguing)
Sorry I'm late.
What's going on here?
He's returned from
another time realm.
Yes. With the stone of time
we can travel to the future
and the past.
-You time traveled?
-Yes.
The stone you can go
wherever you want in time?
Why didn't you go back
and just stop slavery?
That was about state's rights.
Oh, y'all can kiss my ass.
I'm going back to Harlem.
I can't deal with this
no more, man.
Night Pigeon, you rolling?
No. I'm good, man.
I'm just gonna stay.
You going to stay here?
I want his health insurance.
-That don't matter.
-Yes, it do matter.
You got to stand
for something that's
Who do you think is paying
for these wings, man?
His insurance plan.
It's a good plan.
Dental.
Y'all lame as hell, man.
No, I can't do this, man.
They gonna kick y'all ass,
all y'all ass.
9-1-1 What's your emergency?
Are you calling 9-1-1 on me?
Hello?
Yes, you are.
Miss, are you safe?
Y'all some lames.
Woo.
Well that was awkward.
Didn't you guys solve racism
while I was frozen?
It got worse.
Ah, all right.
Well let's go kill some aliens.
That sounds bad.
Let's go defeat the bad guys.